washington hosts cincinnati tonight and
we've spent a lot of time the past few
days talking about the colts and andrew
luck and he's their 24.6 million dollar
per year quarterback and it's a billion
dollar team and why in the heck can't
they figure out what's wrong with his
leg and begin to to solve it and the
cults aren't the only team that's that's
got a problem in that regard and
washington's got multiple issues along
those lines and there's also and we're
going to spend some time talking about
this and if you're a washington fan you
may not like it but there's just a level
of dysfunction in that franchise that
will not dissipate and it seems like
it's gotten worse instead of better
chris most recently this idea that colt
mccoy who was listed as the number one
quarterback on the first depth chart
that came out he's not going to play
tonight he's got lingering soreness in
his leg a leg that he broke last year
and jay gruden the coach of the team
admitted back in march that maybe they
rushed him back to try to see if he'd be
ready for the playoffs if they could
pull it all together and hold it
together because they got off to a good
start last year before alex smith
suffered his badly broken leg and now
colt mccoy because apparently of how his
situation was handled at least in part
because of that still dealing with an
inability to suit up and play the trent
williams situation hovering over the
team he doesn't want to be there because
of the way they handled a tumor a growth
that was on his head
and and i feel like they're completely
mishandling him
i just
look i understand they're trying to get
a new stadium and bruce allen has value
when it comes to that but you know this
team is essentially led by bruce allen
and it just feels like they cannot get
out of their own way even going back to
kirk cousins and how they handle that
that's when it starts
right when scott mccloughan was doing a
great job of amassing talent they came
up with what i believe is a trumped-up
reason to get rid of him
it's just one after another it's amazing
they win any games well i i think you
know it looked like there for a few
years that oh jay gruden's kind of got
things in order there and everything's
looking good but you said it i think the
the kirk cousins thing is the jump off
to where it's led to yeah the last two
years of
not a great look there in washington for
lack of a better phrase it's certainly
not a great look and i think the
questioning of you know the training
staff the weight staff the weight room
staff all that i mean hey the facts are
yes there's issues with guys getting
healthy the washington redskins have
been one of the most injured teams in
football the last two years i believe
they had more starting line offensive
line combinations than any other team in
football last year there's been a number
a number of issues and i know some of
it's bad luck but you know at some point
you got to re you know readjust things
and and maybe change what you're doing
to maybe change that look and the trent
williams situation i mean i don't see
the redskins winning this argument and
he doesn't want to play there i don't
think donald penn goes to signs with
that team at left tackle unless he got
word from trenton williams that i'm not
coming back and yeah well the the
redskins i don't know what to think of
them right now
yeah and with trent williams i mean i
think back to what happened with adrian
peterson after the 2014 season he was at
the point where he wanted a fresh start
he wanted out of minnesota so what did
mike zimmer and rick spielman do they
got in a plane they went to houston they
met with adrian peterson it's time
necessary to get him to understand they
still support him and they still want
him trent williams has had a problem
with the team for months i have never
seen anything or heard anything to
suggest that they have done a single
thing to try to
to to bend a knee and and
you know do whatever they have to do to
convince him that they still love him
and support him and they want him around
and they're sorry if he thinks that
there was something that happened in the
way they treated the tumor slash growth
on his head and they explained it all to
him i mean
there's a level of bedside manner for
lack of a better term that you need to
have as an organization to show these
guys you really care about them and he's
got in the sense they don't care about
him and i don't think they've done
anything to disprove that and and their
strategy for getting him to come back
isn't well you know what well maybe
we'll give him a contract extension give
him a raise whatever it's ah the forty
thousand dollars per day in fines
eventually will cause him to crack well
no it won't and then they refuse to
entertain the possibility of trading him
so he's not going to play for them
they're not going to get anything in
return what do you win from this by
handling it the way that you have and i
just feel like every big decision every
challenge this team has faced they've
come up with a plan that is just dead
wrong from from kirk cousins all the way
through until now and daniel jones
dwayne haskins we hear about that little
civil war within the building going into
the draft process i mean you're right
all of those things
yeah and daniel schneider has not been
as involved as he used to be he used to
be regarded as a guy who just meddled
too much and he would befriend players
and then the players like clinton portis
when he had a problem with the coach
he'd go complain to daniel schneider and
and that just creates even more
dysfunction but it's a different kind of
dysfunction now snyder has kind of faded
out of that role bruce allen's in charge
and bruce allen's primary objective is
to lay the foundation for a new stadium
but he still has his his fingers on the
football organization and and i just i
feel like i don't really know like who's
really running the football operation if
not bruce allen who's making these
decisions is there a collaborative
effort is there really a vision for how
to make this team better or are people
just kind of trying to dog paddle as
best they can until the axe falls on
them yeah i i think it's more of the
latter of what what you're saying and
you know the the to another thing you
said earlier you know you're right they
haven't necessarily
massaged the effort of getting trent
williams back in the building the right
way the only guy i really heard say
really positive things about trent
williams is jay gruden he's you know and
i'm sure he wants him there he's like
what the heck uh i i also know that
there was this prevailing notion out
there in the nfl that really a lot of
people thought once the redskins offered
him a little bit more money he's making
what about 11 million dollars this year
you know that's four or five million
dollars less than guys like taylor juan
or nate solder who
i would say trent williams is certainly
better than those guys trent williams is
in the conversation for the best tackle
in football uh but i don't think that's
going to do it and i think that's what
we're seeing here too money is not the
issue he feels personally burned they
did something wrong and i don't have the
facts or details of this situation but
he feels like they did him dirty whether
they lied to him or i don't know what it
is but he obviously has put his stake in
the ground and wants out of there
yeah this isn't a play to get more money
he has crossed a bridge that he is not
going back over and and the team needs
to make his decisions in light of that
instead of being stubborn instead of
thinking that the mere passage of time
is going to cause this damage to be
undone when you otherwise engage in no
effort to undo the damage
i know the passage of time can be very
helpful in certain contexts but you
can't just sit back and say oh we'll
wait for him to show up you have to do
something to affirmatively make it right
or he's never going to show up and and
and then meanwhile if there are trade
opportunities those are going to uh
potentially not be as good later in the
year as they could be right now but um
you know the trade deadline isn't until
late october and maybe at some point
they'll realize he isn't coming back and
we better get what we can but i can see
this group being sufficiently
hard-headed chris that they don't even
trade him that that look we're sending a
message here whatever the message is
they're sending a message and uh they're
getting nothing out of trent williams in
return for that message so they better
believe it's a very valuable message i
don't know how valuable it is but uh
they're giving up a lot potentially to
send that message yeah they they you
know miss get you know what i'm gonna
say misgaged or you know
misunderstood the situation here in
totality because a little bit too the
value of trent richardson on the trade
market it's going to go down i mean you
know the fact that they didn't really
get a good hold on what the true issue
was here and thinking that they could
just throw money at it
uh now the longer this delays and
lingers that takes the trade value down
for for for uh teams that want to trade
for trent williams because they're
sitting back and they're going to argue
to the redskins well he's not going to
play so
why would a i'm not going to offer you
too much you're not going to get offered
anything here you're going to be stuck
with a guy who's sitting on the
sidelines doing nothing so why don't you
take this offer and i think that takes
away the value a little bit for the
redskins in that department as well the
fact that they've let this linger where
maybe they could have acted and really
got something special in a trade offer
maybe two or three weeks ago
when it didn't seem like this was at the
point of no return
and this is one of the things that
fascinates me about the nfl because the
same human nature that affects
us in every other walk of life every
other industry it it is a factor in
football and i think ego comes into play
here they don't want to admit they were
wrong they don't want to admit they made
a mistake so they just hunker down they
double down and they they continue to
cling to a position that is not going to
be successful for them and through it
all chris they've got a young potential
franchise quarterback they have to
develop and we've talked in the past
about you know if if donov mcnabb landed
in cincinnati and achilles smith landed
in philadelphia back in 1999 would smith
have become a fringe hall of famer and
donovan mcnabb wash out of the league
but but that that first team you play
for as a quarterback has a huge factor
in whether or not you become the best
quarterback you can be and i don't know
that they're going to be able to develop
him because i don't know that they have
the support around him and maybe they're
going to mishandle him and uh and and
he's going to be
uh
not nearly the guy that he could be
because of the organization that he's
playing i think that's a very good point
a real reality uh yeah you're you could
lose important years of growth here for
the player and then just for the player
in general yeah he doesn't get as good
and it could set a false perception
about you early on in your career in the
nfl so yes a lot for for players
especially quarterbacks you know hey
yes talent talent how you can play in
the field is important but a little is
luck to know that you get in the right
situation with a coach who knows how to
groom a quarterback and be creative and
make him look better on the field and of
course the talent around him has
something to do with that as well
yeah and and i know there's going to be
plenty of washington fans out there that
are upset with everything we said over
the last 10 minutes but i'd like to
think that there is a a small percentage
who deep down appreciate the fact that
somebody is holding this group
accountable this has been a team that
has not been successful for way too long
it's been since 1991 that they played in
the nfc championship game and these
reasons that we have been identifying
and trying to flesh out that has a lot
to do with why this team hasn't been
able to take advantage of all the all
the devices that are available to help
teams
every once in a while stumble their way
into contention so uh be mad at us if
you want but i think that that
ultimately calling this out uh is the
only way to make it better for that
franchise
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports